va aller maintenant sur un mec très me
fais
personnellement bien qu'il est chaud
twitter si vous voulez avoir le nouveau
au style weave de cette cuvée il est là
je pense à long terme il ya le sunday
times on va pouvoir regarder choix les
bornes
personne n'en parle vraiment mais c'est
un joueur qui est très efficace qui est
déjà j'ignore qui est expérimenté et et
yves je pense ne va pouvoir va pouvoir
régaler une franchise qui va y aller
second tour
est moins bazar c'est qui ce joueur
incroyable histoire ça avant a pas de
petits articles alors que si vous avez
suivi ce live vous serez prévenus boyard
mais non mais moi je le savais c'était
évident que l'on dessous même ça allait
marcher donc voilà j'espère que je vais
vous convaincre maintenant que je disais
comment fou comme un fou les joueurs
alors allons dès ce william c'est déjà
ma patience affiche envergure qui
s'éteint garde ça ici
voilà vous avez pas sa tête parce qu'il
n'est pas très beau non en réalité c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé une femme
avait une photo et le fichier pnj sauter
fin bref c'est des problèmes de
concret des fiches vous re
300-400 60 jours des fois des trucs qui
saute voilà ça y ressemble pas à ça
c'est notre ancien logo d'ailleurs fois
que le change à lempdes williams c'est
un joueur qui joue au poste de combos
poste un poste 2 1 m 96 92 kg je trouve
pas son envergure parce que c'est un
jour qui est assez peu côté donc il n'a
pas fait les team us et il a pas fait
d des camps qui lui permet des mesures
un peu officiel
il ya une belle longueur je pense qu'il
a une envergure qui est supérieur à sa
taille maintenant j'ai pas envie de vous
dire de conneries avec une info chiffres
on enverra puisqu'il y aura le combined
vous voyez que c'est la troisième année
qui l'a transfert il a fait deux en deux
ans à oklahoma
où ils étaient
majoritairement sortie de bon avec un
faible temps de jeu 18 minutes c'était
le back up de hostile aux bulls qui
maintenant est du côté des lakers est la
vraie bonne surprise peut-être le seul
rayon de lumière de l'année des lakers
ce garde
si si particulier avec un fin fissible
de facteurs qui cross comme à un mek sur
un playground new yorkais on avait fait
une émission underdogs avait l'année
dernière où on disait hostile où il
allait marcher et on nous dit vous avez
prévu mon préféré avec 6 bronn non ce
pas mon préféré que subo o'neal et dont
il va dans les quinze jours qui ne font
plus ce qu'il fait mais moi j'ai dit
bridgett chamois de ce choix donne à ivy
g&g kenta le point jeremy serein devant
mais c'est un joueur qui me fait bien
qui fait
un peu comme des vip duke l'an dernier à
lui de se nouer aussi millièmes bien les
j'aime bien les meneurs les combos
expérimenté avec un vrai dribbles et qui
crée des carres et dont personne ne
parle c'est un peu mon petit petit péché
mignon donc à l'aune des soeurs williams
il était à oklahoma oklahoma change de
coach parce qu'on leur coach est parti à
la retraite ils perdent leur
leurs joueurs majeurs avec au style
width et des transferts et cetera près
du manège maïwenn si amon va du côté de
réguler tout ça donc lui il a la bonne
idée de transférer aussi pour devenir la
tête du projet de wake forest qui est
une équipe qui était assez faible dans
la ici si cette année on voit hélas bien
fait 34 minutes de temps de jeu par
match 14 tirs par match est le plus gros
volume de tir de l'équipe on voit en
termes de stats il tourne à 20 points ce
qui est un des leaders statistiques de
l'aïe 6 6 7 rebonds donc c'est un joueur
qui contribuent aux rebonds 5 passes in
style 0 bloc de cinq blocs 3 709 heures
d'opération à cesson 9h05 skier
moyens ce qui est pas au niveau d'un
meneur de jeu on attend d'avoir un ratio
à deux pouces soit efficace mais on va
le voir qu'il a beaucoup de
responsabilités responsabilité dans
cette équipe excusez moi en termes de
pourcentages on voit qu'il a 62 % de
poids ce qui est intéressant maintenant
va falloir près du cercle à mi distance
et il est à 33% à 3 points avec un vrai
volume de tir
oklahoma et tirez pas du tout on voyait
un tir de tirs en première année
année-là quatre tirs par match et 3 3%
de réussite ce qui est moyen c'est pas
vrai fnai peur mais ferrer qu'il ya un
projet de développement possible autour
de ce jour-là lancers francs on voit
qu'il trompe fait tout - vas y fais tout
à fait tomber excusez moi c'est la
fatigue à force 5 3 lancers francs par
match ce qui est pas mal et en
efficacité
71 % ce qui est assez moyen
encore une fois on va sur les stats
avancer rapidement alors vous voyez il
n'y a pour l'instant pas d'article
dessus pas de scouting les portes ça va
venir au fur et à mesure je veux pas
mettre la pression à steve il y avait
des priorités dans la city c'est normal
si on regarde notre big board alors moi
je n'ai pas mis à jour et qu'on fait la
petite recherche juste comme ça pour
voir à long terme et personne n'en parle
personne ne l'a écoutée chez envergure
parmi nos quatre
quatre scouts alex menu ben adam et moi
je n'avais pas encore mis ce moment là
parce que c'est un joueur que j'avais
pas encore assez vu je préfère les
garder de côté personne n'a mis dans top
30 it up 60 et pour moi c'est une erreur
on va essayer de voir ça ensemble
qu'est ce que ça dit en termes de stats
avancé alors on va aller voir ça si
jamais vous venez d'arriver parce que
j'ai pas fait les choses comme il
fallait vous avez notre board ou lolo
notre board ici vous avez
clayeux
ici et vous avez twitter si jamais vous
avez envie de follow la page envergure
et votre humble serviteur par la même
occasion c'est disponible ici donc voilà
donc on a dit qu'ils jouaient du côté de
wake forest
tout
et si on regarde ça voilà donc plus gros
volume de tir de l'équipe et de loin il
prend son sac on tire de plus que des
clara via qui est le deuxième est la
deuxième star de l'équipe dans sa
répartition beaucoup de tirs près du pas
ni plus de la moitié des harkis son prix
le prix du panier
un petit peu de mi distance en
impression visuelle au début ça a pu
choquer j'en prenais plus que ça mais
finalement assez peu un petit ami
distance et 30% à 3 points donc ce qui
est une belle progression par rapport à
ce qu'ils aient oklahoma on voit que
majoritairement c'est un joueur qui doit
se créer ses propres tiers
28% seulement près du panier passe
décisive donc c'est un joueur qui va pas
dans le coeur mais qui va vraiment une
balle en main de a à z quand il prend à
mi distance
vous considérez que c'est que du pool up
jamais de sortie d'écran et catch and
shoot et à trois points par contre c'est
plus un joueur qui va être sur ducati
ajouta sera ce secteur là voilà
maintenant en termes de réussite
67% près du cercle ce qui est vraiment
bien on rappelle que dès lors notre ami
luis militer à 54% après dubai et hopper
67% après 10 heures ce qui est bien
c'est ça qui fait tomber très souvent
des lancers-francs lorsqu'il y va à
mi-distance 45%
et mi distance qui est une très bonne
réussite 7 à jour qui lorsqu'il va être
en poule va vraiment réussir à se créer
un écart et être efficace et à trois
points on l'a vu 33 % ce qui est moyen
mais comme c'est un joueur qui commence
à tirer que cette année c'est un beau
signe d'espoir alors je vais pas non
plus et c'est sûrement de le projet on
n'est pas sur un spécialiste snipers
d'accord on n'est pas sur un mec qui
va sanctionner systématiquement catch
and shoot pour avoir une petite
comparaison parce que je compare avec
notre ami au steel wheels on peut aller
regarder
tout ça me permettra de voir les stats
mois dernier de notre ami alan doss
williams du côté d'oklahoma oklahoma qui
est ici
donc les néons vainqueur dès 2020-2021
donc austin oui les deux voiliers exact
est un joueur qui prenait qui est
efficace à 55% près du tien qui crée pas
mal qui était aussi dans les mêmes
présentable à mi distance avec aussi
beaucoup de poules up et qui a trois
points était à 30% seulement mais lui
pour le comprenait beaucoup plus de tirs
difficiles d'accord quand il est en cas
de doute il était bien plus efficace à
noter ce william c'était ici je rends
volumes beaucoup plus bas même s'il a
quand même pris 135 tir en 18 minutes
non qui il essayait pas mal de marques
et un dynamiteur de bons et on avait des
stats à peu près similaire avec moins
d'efficacité à mi distance et à trois
points on le voyait le volume était
beaucoup trop fait beau il était un an
par match voilà pour maintenant les
jours le film qu'est ce qu'on va
regarder chez ce joueur qu'est c'que
t'es resté on va regarder son dribble
avant tout
parce qu'il a un vrai vrai trip c'est un
joueur qui est capable de changer de
direction c'est un joueur qui est
capable
d'accélérer de décès les répondants sont
brèves qui étudie sa longueur pour
pouvoir casser le rythme qu'il ya un
vrai cross c'est un mec on va regarder
aussi qui est capable de naviguer dans
des petits espaces c'est à dire que
lorsqu il va y avoir un pick and roll je
peux passer entre les défenseurs s'il ya
une
une aide qui vient je peux gérer mon
tempo recul et faire un kit sur le côté
si jamais il ya une prise à deux je peux
sortir de la prison de naviguer
ressortir le ballon normal à c'est
vraiment un joueur qu'un dribble fiable
et qui va perdre des ballons plus sur
des soies dépasse idiote soit parce que
comme c'est la menace principale de
l'équipe et les surcharger
plutôt parce qu'ils manquent de deux
terribles à proprement parler
contrairement à bhl equity qu'on ait vu
avant c'est un joueur qui est plus près
et qui est capable de bâtir dès demain
on va commencer par ce secteur là
appreniez à chaud le pick and roll parce
que c'était faux nobles principal
antillais et on verra si on peut le
projetant une bière on finira par le tir
j'ai peu de clips défensif parce qu'en
réalité c'est un joueur qui défend assez
peu à wake forest parce qu'il fait
tourner tac d'accord donc j'ai pas
énormément juste sa défense et à
quelques clips et on va c'est juste
d'extrapoler par ses qualités
athlétiques mais je vais pas vous
revendre un projet défensif
parce qu'en réalité
on s'y est il le fait très très peu
c'est pas qui défend pas taxe soit
mauvais défenseur mais qu'il est peu
appliquée qui les armes ont mis sur lot
donc on va voir dans son dribble
quand je vous dit capable de changer de
direction capable d'accélérer capable de
changer de mains capables de partir dès
demain
vraiment il ya beaucoup de contrôles je
trouve que c'est un joueur qui est très
plaisant gradés qui est très smooth qui
va souvent créé quelque chose là où il
ya rien avant et nouvelle écoute et je
vous laisse les clips un peu tourné pour
kiffer et puis ensuite on fait du
ralenti on fait du prime
je vous ai mis pas mal de clips vous
allez voir où le dribble est incroyable
et la finition elle plus kaka
c'est un joueur qui des fois c'est d'en
faire trop qu'il veut faire des choses
très compliquées en voulant faire des
choses très compliquées parce que c'est
pas un athlète verticale supérieur peut
rater définition facile donc
vous allez voir qu'il ya des supers
dribble
mais que des fois il ya des un problème
de finition
un peu dommageable
voilà donc bon bah on va faire du coup
les clips un parent au ralenti et cetera
jeu mais pose
on va essayer de quitter plein écran ci
veut bien
on va y aller tranquille demain
alors
yumiko
donc quand je vous dit capable de partir
de demain le premier pas il est assez
explosif entre élites mais ce qui fait
surtout très bien ce qu'est capable de
changer de mains l'on voit que on part
main droite on a un départ ma droite ou
bien passé un dribble dans le dos on
repasse sur sa main gauche et ensuite on
a une belle allonge pour pouvoir aller
finir près du panier
et encaissé le contact à jour qui
rechigne pas à aller au contact et qui
utilise bien les angles de son corps
pour pouvoir trouver un accès au niveau
du cercle
donc là on va encore avoir un drive au
niveau de la main droite
je crois ouais on repart ma droite et on
va voir au niveau de sa navigation
encore une fois dans la longueur capable
de naviguer
et de venir chercher avec quelque chose
assez acrobatique un lay up
sur un contrat défenseur entre armando
bécotte de jouer ici si tu as he
athlétisme qui peut être un bon rhume
protecteurs
dont clip suivant voilà encore une fois
quand je vous dis qu'on peut le changer
de direction alors là il y aura pas la
finition sur ce clip là mais cette
capacité à vite changer de rythme la vie
de changer de direction donc la ja la
ch'ti du mali m'intéresse moins donc on
part ma droite on revient magot jour par
main droite dans une accélération et
après on essaie d'aller finir au cercle
là elle ne met pas très sûr et le manioc
là on passe ma gauche on repasse ma
droite et on vient avec sa longueur et
c'est de finir au cercle on aurait
peut-être sifflé une faute sur ce cette
action là
il aura une prochaine fois ici on est
main droite on repasse main gauche on
revient à droite encore une fois et par
sa longueur on essaie de trouver là on
le rate contre florida state encore une
fois mais
vraiment cette capacité à changer de
direction et à faire travailler les
rotations des hanches de l'adversaire
qui souvent lui permet de marquer
facilement et là on l'a vu en transition
face à hewitt 6
donc là on est sur un pick and roll
quand je vous dit capable de gérer son
dribble moi je trouve que cette
navigation balle en main est vraiment
exceptionnel alors d'ariary fait le
mauvais choix parce que la défense est
vraiment concentré sur lui donc on voit
ici peace and roll il ya une aide qui
vient attaquer la balle sur sa main
droite du coup je repasse ma gauche et
net qui vient attaquer main gauche
repasse ma droite et au lieu de cliquer
ici pour un joueur ouvert je vais tenter
un flotteur runner beaucoup trop
compliqué
c'est pour ça que quand on va parler
ensuite de la passe il ya un défaut
pour être vraiment un bonheur à
proprement parler ici je vous propose
dans le dos et encore une fois on a un
contact et en dribles j'aime créer un
accès au niveau du panier la département
à gauche j'accepte le contact et je vais
finir à travers lui et je vais trouver
là faut donc c'est un joueur qui va
souvent auxerre qu'on a vue qui fait
tout le monde se montrent souvent tomber
des lancers francs maintenant au terme
de maturité physique il a trois ans déjà
dans le développement ici
qu'est ce que je note la main gauche et
pourra vous pour être assez rare
efficace j'aime bien être capable de
venir dès demain ici on vient on voit
que c'est un joueur qui peut utiliser la
planche et finir de la main gauche donc
capable d'utiliser ma droite la gauche
est de faire le bon choix en fonction de
ce que donne la défense ici le petit
minet doubt et ensuite je vais finir
tranquillement ses dribbles là je le
trouve encore une fois incroyable
vraiment comment on va à petit comme si
inné note tout simplement se débarrasser
de défenseur direct je crois que c'est
un peu quel blog qui est sur lui et elle
est marquée au panier tranquillement
donc là je pars main gauche je m'arrête
je fais tomber le mot défenseurs et puis
je vais aller finir au serbe derrière et
encore une fois vraiment sur ce match je
l'aï lavé du caca dans les yeux je vais
rater la finition caen - dire on veut
faire en français un mouvement un
million d'euros une finition à 50
centimes voilà cette capacité à
s'arrêter et repartir qui en font
vraiment un joueur très efficace badr
ici en accélération et encore une fois
je vais chercher quelque chose de
beaucoup trop compliqué quand nous la
voler comme me l'a dit ces gens qui
tentent des choses trop difficile
quelque chose acrobatique alors qu'il
peut tout simplement finir comme ça avec
la faute voilà et aprilia la petite
reine jeunes derrière ça c'est un show
men and all the williams qui nous régale
du côté de wake forest et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de responsabilités balle en
main ce qui explique aussi le déchet
voilà
donc ça pour de la nba
on va le voir ailleurs très beaux jours
de pick and roll c'est pas un meneur
principal tout simplement c'est un
joueur qui peut dans une équipe liens
forts bollène l'heure où sur un banc
venir créer de l'attak rapidement venir
récupérer un ballon partir andrev
contrôler et pouvoir dans une défense
qui va être moins resserrer sur lui où
il y avait il va pas être la star de
l'équipe pouvoir tout simplement finir
de façon intéressante au niveau du
panier je vous ai montré beaucoup
d'action qui finissent avec du d on a vu
tout à l'heure qu'il a vidé 65 % de
réussite au cirque donc on va alité il
ya quand même un joueur qui est capable
de finir et efficacement maintenant sur
pick'n roll
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir regarder
comme je voulais distinctes qui navigue
très bien et qui surtout un très beau
pour le premier distance on a dit en nba
le mi distance ça revient à la mode et
en plus de ça il ya beaucoup de drops
dont il ya beaucoup d' espace donc on le
voit c'est un joueur qui est très à
l'aise pour pouvoir s'élever
les quizz n'y en avait il dit qu on
l'orienté mangochie poule hop parce
qu'il n'avait pas le choix à l'aune des
sous il ya ce parti en dribbles a le
luxe de pouvoir décider s'il veut
prendre un poulpe parce que la défense
lui donne ou si valeo dribbles il est
capable de bâtir dès demain et du coup
il est capable de remettre en place dès
demain donc on va le voir par exemple
ici pick and roll le défenseur est
beaucoup trop bas
eh ben je vais aller prendre le meilleur
choix possible dans un second temps
choix les clips je vous ai mis c'est pas
sa vraie jour de drive in teak
et surtout c1 c'est un des meilleurs
passeurs au no look de toutes les haines
si et quand je vous parle de showman il
ya de ça aussi c'est qu'il ya une très
très bonne manipulation visuel il
regarde pas du tout là il va transmettre
le ballon ce qui le rend assez
imprévisibles pour les défenses parfois
pour ses coéquipiers aussi ce qui lui
permet de trouver des joueurs ouvert
assez facilement
et là encore une fois ya un côté un peu
au style width voilà on sent qu'il a
passé deux ans avec lui donc vous allez
voir des très très beau renversement à
une main capable de passer à une main
dès demain en au look capable de faire
une passe directe il passe au sol d'une
passe lobée sa joueur assez complet des
fois il va rater sur pick'n roll
aujourd'hui tiennent pop un coéquipier
il est plus à l'aise en ski et le kick
et c'est pour ça que tu crois pas
particulièrement meneur principal mais
quand même de très très gros flash à la
basse à ce niveau la scène puis des
flashs c'est vraiment une belle
efficacité à la passe qui fait que très
rapidement il peut s'intégrer dans un
roster nba sur un banc en tant que
vétéran dans une équipe compétitive et
il fluidifie n'attaque accélérée du
tempo et et créer du jeu
maintenant on va aller chaud le clip a
pas individuel pour admirer ses passes
nos looks au ralenti et j'espère vous
après vous convaincre du coup jour
pourquoi est ce qu'il faudra fêter à
l'aune des soeurs williams surtout si on
le draft pourquoi sera drafté trop bas
et du coup pourquoi est-ce que ce spa
un petit style tu donc la pick and roll
je refuse l'écran alors je vais pardon
je vais essayer de le remettre ça que ça
va trop vite donc voilà je refuse
l'écran et je vais les finir main droite
il a une belle longueur non capacité là
dessus de pouvoir sur la défense en
prenant dans l'écran
j'oriente et je pars main gauche poule
up alors on voit qu'il ya un boeing time
son camp il prend son poulain pnb
l'élévation il reste longtemps en l'air
il va vraiment avoir un à mi distance
assez plein
mais très efficace n'a eu à 45 100 de
réussite
donc là la défense ici au niveau du cran
la défense et de l'orienter dans laxe
pour avoir dans cette faute de zone une
surcharge et lukas et l'accès au ballon
le test par lukas et l'accès à son
driver du club j'ai lâché le ballon donc
lui il ya un écran il part ma gauche il
va revenir ma droite et comme le
défenseur est très bas capacité à bouloc
et à finir efficacement voilà une belle
lecture défensive et il a le luxe de
pouvoir choisir ce que la défense donne
ici c'est pareil
après l'écran je vois qu'armando bécoter
très bas et donc je vais pouvoir prendre
un pool up no contesté à mi distance
encore une fois on l'orientent l'a cette
fois ci la défense n'est pas placé
correctement sonné pour une transition
on est toujours une zone surtout il va
pouvoir piquer nos classiques ma droite
le défenseur est trop bas pour leurs
distances en efficacité
clip suivant on a un défenseur qui lui
met de la pression bel écran je navigue
je repasse main droite et la drive et
netiq avec manipulation visuel donc si
on le regarde ici
je suis main gauche je regarde dans laxe
la défense on le voit se reconcentre
dans laxe décor c'est la menace
principale est visuellement je quitte ma
main droite pour un tir à trois points
qui cette fois ci fera ficelles
autres pick and roll
donc je repasse main gauche parce qu'on
oriente là bas et encore une fois en au
look je vais chez point de perdre points
qui lui ne rentrera pas
mais tu as réussi à créer
un tir ouvert
ici à une main par dessus l'épaule le
joueur refuse le tire ici
mais en nba ça c'est un tir ouvert
donc la peace and roll
encore cette défense qui va surcharger
pour l'empêcher de venir très élevé au
niveau du panier
je m'enfonce et j'ai un kick
jean mon côté gauche
encore une fois si la manipulation
visuels en drive and click je vais pas
le faire de pouce dessus vous avez
compris le principe
donc la piste and roll je pars main
gauche
est encore une fois en au look alors là
pas c'est pas hyper précisant on voit
qu'elle n'arrive pas directement dans la
main du tireur
ça c'est le fait de vouloir faire du
show
si on regarde la
pop
et la passe le
shooter dans le canard est obligée
d'allonger et de se remettre avec ce
qu'il fait perdre du temps au niveau de
son tir est ce qui permet à la défense
de se replacer mais moi encore une fois
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la manipulation
visuel la capacité à créer de lille
parce que la défense n'attend pas
on est sûr de la transition
et encore une fois manipulation elle est
magnifique
pour un jour qu'ils coupent au panier
là je me remets post pas capable de
passer à une main pour un que dans laxe
donc voilà
je pense qu'il va rester en transition
nous sommes une passe de relance tout
simple mais qui sait faire et je crois
qu'il en est la dernière en transition
et celle là les plus impressionnantes
avec une bonne passe
voilà petites passes 1 rebond dans la
course
de toute beauté
et fera ce type volley-ball avec
finition donc globalement on l'a vu
c'est un joueur qui sur pick'n roll est
capable de créer bâlois - est-ce qu'il
aura le ballon nba
en tant que porteur secondaire sur du
banc
dans une équipe compétitive qui va avoir
besoin de rajouter un dû un vétéran qui
peut faire des choses rapidement il va
pas falloir aussi pour ça qu'ils
puissent mettre du côté sud à trois
points c'est ce qu'on va aller regarder
matt aujourd'hui de tir est-ce que andes
williams est capable de tirer on a vu 33
% de réussite
majoritairement catch and shoot on va
regarder ça change de la mécanique du
coup
donc ici les mâles sont prêtes la balle
arrive au niveau de sa main gauche
et ça rentre
ici alors on voit que au niveau du tir
c'est fluide mais il ya un petit temps
d'adaptation quand même c'est pas
attraper je dégaine ya tant de
réajustement qui des fois il fait perdre
du temps et du coup
qui le rend peu moins efficace alors là
on voit qu'il avait contre lui et s'il
était en feu
beaucoup de couleurs très statique moi
ya pas de dry pour créer un écart c'est
vraiment du sport tas fasse pareil à mi
distance on le voit il ya beaucoup de
tirs qui sont pris sur la face tu n'es
pas un écart de créer donc ça c'est pas
des tirs auxquels je crois en nba
moi je vais lui demander vraiment
simplement d'être temps les corners et 2
et de finir je vous ai mis enfin des
séquences poste bas parce que c'est un
joueur qui sait on verra si c'est une
arme qui sera utile ou pas en une 6ème
et qui reconnaît à mi ce match qui est
assez puissant et du coup qui enfonce
bien post bac qui par sa longueur arrive
à trouver des bras roulé donc voilà et
enfin pour la défense on voit que c'est
un joueur qui peut être battu alors vous
voyez pas sur le défenseur principal
mais c'est un joueur qui peut être battu
sur des chants des démarquages joies du
ballon et sait jamais qui est
intéressant pour apporter note dans le
second rideau c'est un mec on va
toujours placé sur le mois bon retour de
balle adverses
voire parfois en poste d'ailier jusqu'à
taille de cachemire mais qui sera pas
une menace au niveau du tiers qui sera
plus là pour comme vous voyez ici
je remets en ralenti provoqué une petite
aide pour faire lâcher le ballon
et qui ensuite se repositionnera qui
sera vraiment l'oncle et battu ici qui
sera vraiment un mec
qui défendra les robert covington qui
défendra les gars place dans les
coronaires les mecs de course comme ça
et qui sera jamais faso au porteur star
de leur équipe voilà c'était ainsi une
petite séquence quelques petits bugs
donne sur à l'aune des sweeps pack
énormément de choses at her dessus de
plus mais moi les qualités du joueur son
qi basket sont sa maturité son passing
game mais son dribble font que je
l'achète
je vais l'acheter
excusez moi sur de la
fin de premier tour c'est au tour
réalité j'ai pas de renneville 30 45 et
je suis assez convaincu que peu importe
où il va il sera il devra contribuer est
il aurait une chance en nba
ça dépendra du contexte je le vois bien
faire une belle somme euroligue l'aide
de la g-league et j'espère qu'il aura
une opportunité parce que ça peut être
une vraie pépite à l'image d'un style
weave et à l'image d'un mec auquel il
ressemble aussi que j'aimais beaucoup ce
dernier dévie juke qui a été drafté par
brooklyn et
qui jouent peu je crois cette année j'ai
pas trop regarder pour clint internet en
dehors des matchs contre chicago mais
qui joue peu et femmes et auquel je
crois donc voilà tout simplement
et puis bon on va pouvoir finir cela est
violent
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis on
est à peu près en moyenne 7 suit dix
personnes pendant se lève donc c'était
hyper cool pour un petit live d'après
midi on se retrouve vendredi soir pour
un live avec alan où on va regarder du
challenge national y en avait déjà fait
de jouer ensemble
mais on n'avait n'avait pas fait avec
alan donc alan ses joueurs qu'ils aiment
bien les douanes montrent qu'à un avis
qui a évolué donc on va se refaire avec
son sa vision à lui parce que toujours
intéressant de comparer les avis on va
aussi regarder
du scot et barnes normalement on a une
pièce voir l'adaptation nba scotsman ce
qui était mon jeu l'an dernier le jour
que j'ai hâte mais en deuxième position
de mon board et donc j'étais persuadé
que ça allait fonctionner donc on va
regarder ce qui donne du côté de toronto
et puis d'un troisième joueur peut-être
sophomore on essaie de vous préparer ça
pour un petit live qualité qualitatif
vendredi sur des horaires un peu plus
classique on se retrouvera je pense aux
alentours de 21h 21h30 on vous tient au
courant
tous les cas sur les réseaux sociaux
n'hésitez pas à follow envergure sur
twitter mais surtout à flot cette chaîne
twitch si c'est pas fait pour ne pas
rater nos prochains live qu'ils ne le
faisaient pas la native twitter si vous
avez envie de vous abonner c'est du
bonus nous ça nous permet derrière de
financer notre matos et pourquoi pas je
vous renvoie racks et à la synergie
basket pour avoir une base de données
beaucoup plus intéressante et des clips
de meilleure qualité voilà c'est si
jamais l'envié vous prend et que votre
vie c'est cucchi quand maudit
sinon on verra car tu es toujours un
article ou un scout report par jour des
podcasts men a plein qui vont arriver là
il joue tease un peu on va parler encore
de la victoire l on va aller aussi du
côté de la haie 6,6 avec des meneurs qui
joue dans la hesse ici peu de mecs qui
peuvent être considérées lottery pick et
puis vous avez
voilà du contenu du contenu qui arrive
régulièrement et bientôt bientôt faut
planifier sa il ya pierre qui nous
ferait un planet draft on ira un peu
fourre nos chouchous donc voilà ne ratez
pas une miette du contenu envers dior on
espère que ça va vous plaire on va vous
accompagner jusqu'à la draft et puis moi
de mon côté personnel va écouter
il ya mon board que je vais actualiser
la dans la semaine vu que je suis arrêté
pour problème cervicales je vais avoir
le temps de remplir mon bordée de
refermer dernière petite note et puis
sur mon compte twitter je vous ai
préparé
une série de ce raid où vous avez je
vais vous faire voilà avec des clips ce
qu'ont pu faire un peu la destinée
report et cetera choix des joueurs que
je traite pas cher envergure si jamais
vous avez envie évidemment twitter
qu'elle allait le lien envergure surtout
qui est le plus le plus important est et
on va se faire des gros bisous on va
saisir à tout bientôt sur twitter et
bientôt sur twitter et bientôt sur
envergure tout court
et puis passer une bonne soirée
merci d'avoir été là bon appétit à ce
qu'ils vont manger bon courage à ceux
qui vont travailler et on se retrouve
tout tout tout bientôt à chao deep sea